If you don't care about your
privacy, that's your privilege.
But as a society, we can't
afford to give up on privacy,
just like we can't afford to
give up on free speech. My name
is Arvind Narayanan. I'm a
professor of computer science at
Princeton University. One of the
areas that I study is AI. I've
also done a lot of research on
privacy. What connects these
topics is, I'm motivated by tech
accountability. Back in 2006,
Netflix released the movie
viewing records of a half a
million of their customers. And
this was for the purpose of a
machine learning competition.
What they had said was that
because the customers had been
de-identified because their
names were not attached to those
movie viewing records, there was
nothing to be concerned about
from a privacy perspective. At
the time, I was doing my PhD.
And so my advisor, Vitaly
Shmatikov and I, we smelled a
rat. I wondered, could we cross
correlate people's reviews on
IMDB with the set of movies that
they had watched on Netflix. And
we were able to show that that
was possible in some cases. So
that's when I first started
recognizing that the assurances
that companies might give people
on privacy might not, in fact,
stand up to scrutiny. One of the
other areas where I was hearing
this a lot is, yeah, yeah, we're
tracking everything you're doing
on your apps, but it's all
anonymous. So we started to look
into that. And we just, you
know, we fell into this whole
minefield of, you know, the
really, really invasive, sneaky
tracking that's happening on our
devices. And no, it's not really
all anonymous, because it might
be attached to something like
your so called hashed email
address, and it can be used to
connect all of your profiles
from one device to another. And
so it can still be used to build
this one kind of uber profile of
you. And there are dozens of
companies that specialize in
doing that. One thing we didn't
expect, when we started doing
all this privacy research is
that it would be Silicon Valley
versus Silicon Valley. Today,
probably the biggest protector
of privacy is Apple, perhaps
even more effective than a lot
of the privacy regulations
around the world, which are
certainly also important. A lot
of AI technologies today do have
powerful capabilities, but they
also have important limits. And
so we should be very careful
about relying on them. There are
many kinds of technologies that
are clubbed under this umbrella
term AI. Often, these
technologically have very little
to do with each other, except
that they're all forms of
machine learning, they learn
from data. And just because
technology is quickly moving in
one type of AI, most notably
generative AI recently, doesn't
mean that all of these other
applications of AI are getting
better or more accurate. It
doesn't mean necessarily that
they should be used at all. I've
had this suspicion for many,
many years now that a lot of the
AI technologies that are being
sold to predict people's future
behavior don't actually work.
These kinds of algorithms are
used by banks for lending.
They're used by insurance
companies. This is happening in
hiring when people apply for
jobs. This is happening even in
the criminal justice system,
when it comes to decisions about
bail and parole. When you look
at the accuracy of these models,
it's barely better than random.
So is it ethical to make these
consequential decisions about
people when they're only
slightly more accurate than the
flip of a coin? That's one issue
with these things. There are
Well known racial biases and
other kinds of biases in these
models. As a kid, I thought of
technology as automatically a
force for good. But what I
started to realize growing up
that what tech does is it
amplifies both the best and the
worst of society. Machine
learning algorithms are
fundamentally about finding
patterns in a data set, and then
reflecting those patterns in
their outputs. So ultimately,
any of these datasets is
generated by people. And people
live in a society. And so there
are both individual biases and
the structural biases of society
itself, that are almost always
captured. When it comes to AI
and fairness, who gets to decide
is really the elephant in the
room. And I think that's perhaps
the most important question.
Does the decision maker or the
developer of the algorithm, have
a process to get community input
from various stakeholders from
the people who are going to be
subjected to these decisions and
try to figure out what all the
different trade offs are? I
think even when a technology
gets very rapidly deployed, and
it's beneficial to those in
positions of power, when
everyday people feel that it's
unjust, they can and have been
able to successfully push back
and that should be front of mind
for us when we see dubious
applicantions of technology, we
shouldn't take it for granted